New York City New York the boys are
coming to the great white way on
Broadway at the Town Hall theater May
9th standup comedy Kippy and I co-
headline then we play the little a with
the crowd it's the biggest show we've
ever done we want to sell it out come
out and see us yeah get your tickets at
R garbage.com where the ru garbage card
game is available right now for sale
it's it's over 50 of our favorite
questions from the show some you have
heard some you haven't heard it's a good
time get it play with your friends find
out who's trash yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite podcast this is R you garbage
oh yeah it's that little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that if they good to be classy
don't they're just a big old piece of
trash trash trash trash I'm your host T
FY coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at toties in the new
edition she is upstairs getting dinner
ready okay my co-host is coming at you
from across the table he loves a Mr this
guy she's a working girl you know he's
the CEO of R you garbage International
businessman and don't forget he's going
to be having a big kegger this weekend
when his parents are away give it up for
young Kevin James Ryan everybody what's
up fellow kids how you doing uh first of
all please make sure you rate you
subscribe on iTunes which by the way I
think that's a thing again get back and
start dropping them reviews we
appreciate the love and obviously full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are true to R cooking then
obviously the greatest website of all
time you go over there www.patreon.com
garbage you sign up you get over a
bajillion hours of bonus content baby
it's fantastic over there and we just
had I got to say maybe an all time one
of the best alltime EPS of hard feelings
talk about taking a left down to fville
baby I've got more message nice down
this time of year I've got more messages
about this episode than I think anything
ever and do yourself a favor get over to
that rug garbage.com pick up yourself
the brand new second edition of the ru
garbage card game and pick up some ticks
for May 9th and come see the boys at the
Town Hall theater in New York City it's
the biggest show we've ever done we want
to see is all there and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinary the old magic man makes us
all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours he crosses the
te's and he dots the eyes and it's a in
the word of that hillbilly doctor that
gave birth to him holy boy that thing is
huge should name that boy Willie demonic
scruin Telly Big M what up dude I was
working on that for like four hours oh
that was great busy day huh yo I
couldn't get it out I look like sweet
Lord the size of that thing yo this
looks like I'm looking at detention like
K be just caught with a paintball gun in
his locker and Foley's having to sit him
down and give him a talking know what
are you a Transit cop what man
fuing it's laundry day and I ran out of
product I'm dying over here you've been
doing the backwards hat a lot yeah I do
it it's nice it's a it's a switch up man
I uh I'm trying to re retap into my
[__] my young school Roots you know
what I mean I was thinking about uh
about T-Bone today they all had to know
when you were growing up right like your
mom and dad were like changing you and
stuff like that I don't think it get big
as it I don't know mine's never gotten
big but I don't think it's big it got
it's got to get turned on at a certain
age can I let you in on the pure
psychosis that has walking around
changing the diaper it's falling out and
stuff it's hanging out the side of the
diaper God
damn dad's like I don't know what the
big deal
is it's all proportionate my mom's
handed me the bills and
[__] got to been sit at the head of the
table since you were 13 so here's the
here's the skinny boys here's the thick
nothing skinny about
that so as you know I went to a boarding
gude get in here look at this thing this
episode's flagged for sure dude I went
to boarding school as you know uhhuh so
around 14 in two
rooms got to check that thing keep that
in the closet so around 14 I'm I'm
sitting there you know there's Hogs all
around I want to have a cool hog I do
the mental math I've never talked about
this publicly I did the mental math my
body's growing this is my only chance at
it I started doing dick exercises really
what I heard that's what happened to
Tommy Lee too that was the myth back in
the day he did something working it out
I guess I was hting the gym really what
like like the thrust and stuff I tied to
the back of a
car have it beat up haveen it beat up a
piece of meat sir do you have three
three
dumbbells I wish I was joking but I did
I did all types of cooky [__] exercises
man really that was my problem yeah I
should have done that not been Irish I
got a real I got a real couch potato on
there I got to whip my guy into shape
talk about a hypothesis you can never
put to the test of course
yeah geez okay well now you
know bab what if I start now there you
go you think that's a possibility I
don't that maybe maybe with some plastic
surgery I don't know if that pelaton can
work that kind of magic yeah you're
going to need a plane ticket to Greece
or something dude hey they did whoever's
playing ball I'm
in gang as you know we're here for a
little family episode just the boys the
bozos and the homies it's good to see
you fellas yeah it's nice nice to see
you I got a little thing I was uh
obviously we talk about uh car
accessories a lot on the program it's
been well uh well documented aftermarket
aftermarket things and one of the big
things that a lot of people do which I
always kind of like I think it is trashy
but I always I always kind of liked if
it's done right it looks good is
like the bandana I would never do it but
the bandana on the headrest sometimes
headrest yeah you know how like there's
the headrest on the seat rearview mirror
what headrest it's Muffler tailpipe do
you know what a headrest is yeah it's oh
okay put your bandana on that people do
it as like a cover like they'll like
they'll like wrap it around mm never
seen it put gohe or like a headrest
cover you I've seen them put like a mask
in the driver in the passenger side so
people think that's what happened scared
the [__] [__] somebody put a ski mask
on theirs I thought the Ops was after me
on the New Jersey turn Bike Dude I it
was raining and I thought that dude I it
was like a scene from the town I thought
I was getting God I thought it was over
at you oh dude it was [__] they were
it was this mini van and they were
hanging behind me and I'm like what the
[__] I looked just pictured a guy with
an AK coming at me scared the [__] out
ofy you can't be do is that like a a a
car pool Lane thing maybe I think it's a
so you stay away from the car you don't
ride Rob the car that you think
somebody's in there you can't really
tell if somebody's in there okay I don't
know if that would work for the carpol
lane yeah I don't know I don't do they
enforce that I don't even know if they
enforce that I guess if you get pulled
over yeah they I'll risk it I'm a badass
I'll risk it they also switched it I
don't know what it's like in your local
state or
um County but uh took me a minute Jesus
Christ uh it's three now you got to have
three people in the car used to be two
uh-huh now you got to have three who the
[__] driving around with three people
I'll do it it's me my wife and my dog
three grown men in a car together it's
the weirdest thing ever we do it all the
time we've done it all over the country
hey we're strange and we're we're a
little creepo uh we all have masks on um
yeah it's to get people to commute from
like around New York it's to get people
in Jersey who are driving in of like
meet up grab a grab a gaggle of people
my sister did that every day to school
what what do you mean she or uh to uh to
work she worked uh pretty far away and
then uh another person like lived by her
so they drove to work every day for like
15 years together yeah they would take
turns and I'm like what if it sucked how
do you get out of that oh man I don't
like I guess it didn't I don't like
talking to anybody ever oh that's brutal
I used to take the train home when I
worked in new rochell I would take the
train back down to the city the uh MTA
like the you know what is it called the
MTH no but the long railroad no Metro
North met North I would take the Metro
North classy operation what no no in
name sure I'll give you that leave thank
you up on the Metro North uh hey leave
at a grand central Grand Central is a
nice train station if you're trying to
cop heroin n no the one part of it's
nice there's a couple award-winning
restaurants in there too there's a place
with the oyster's like an oyster famous
Oyster Bar Michael Jordan
steakhous where we always take it three
I don't going to say go for the extra
point Steve her
Footwear what he's on the team man I
used to get a bacon egg and cheese in
the in Grand Central it was it would
wherever if I was going somewhere man it
would blow your socks St right was there
was a bagel joint right in the corner
there oh my God yeah my brother took the
train in all the time when he was living
in Philly and and working up here and
they all knew each other it was all
everybody on Amtrak and they would all
sit in like the business thing sure the
same guys on the 85 they all knew each
other and man I tell you they were real
territorial about where they sat if they
weren't sitting in like the right they
start screaming at each other who are
you and you can't sit there and this and
that it's a [__] high school over
here you guys make like 400 Grand a year
what do you do it I know what are you
taking a goddamn train for anyway I used
to do it when I had to take SEPTA from
Summerton down down into Center City I'm
talking about I know but we would
talking about Titans of
Industry not you on your way to finish
line I was working in bookkeeping at the
time I it's crazy I was account crazy
you know bookkeeping I I don't know it I
was working in it I should say um
explains all the all the envelopes in
Toy's
mailbox those trash people are looking
for us I think I don't know what you're
doing over and that shit's in my name
too it's on auto pay it should be oh
[__] I think we cancelled that card I
got to look into that I'm bad at bills
they got to dump trash in front of the
building like in [__] Sopranos [__]
rat knocks on the door um [__] I got to
look into that that you don't want to
cross it you don't want to cross oh my
God I just realized something too I got
knocked for uh a late payment on
something on my credit report through me
I don't how would I know I don't know
what was it they didn't I didn't say cuz
when you look if you look for it then
they hit you again I don't want to run
my credit report because then they knock
you again should tell knock me down like
no it just says one delinquent one Mis
payment and I got everything all
straightened out as far as I
know I'm 716 checked last night 716
pretty good that's not bad mhm out of
5,000 it's not bad at all no yeah I'm
feeling maybe that was it what would
they knock your credit report for not
paying your [__] uh trash people I
know great that's not that's not an
organization you want to get into bed
with bookkeeping
huh skimming book skimming uh but they
get real so like hold on so you know
credits and debits and stuff like that
sure cuz they always confuse I mix them
up from time to time yeah it cuz a debit
you debit your account is a positive you
credit your account it's a negative yeah
but don't they switch it up at some
point but a debit card you take money
out and a credit card I don't know it
was something in high school that
confused the [__] and credits yeah yeah
your te I think they call them like your
t t box or something my lacrosse coach
was the teacher so it didn't matter but
still it could have been jam up City I
hated our basketball coach was our
accounting coach nice yeah I hated all
that dumb [__] that we had to learn that
didn't that's the stuff you need for
light you didn't need trigonometry I
didn't need any of it just the cooking
class find yourself a Gippy the home the
home class is the only time that ninth
grade science is really the only time I
learned anything and and my English
literature classes that I took shout out
to Mr blanch [__] best M and Mr Kelly
yeah shout out to you guys I think
they're listening I think Mr blanch
passed away okay and there we are it's a
record [__] 9 Minutes in you bring up
a dead guy and I loved him he was a good
teacher you know you had that one good
teacher that was awesome I don't think I
had that many oh I had a couple I had a
couple I had I I had a couple that were
like decent younger like the the the
elementary school teachers like those
those women were great they were
fantastic I hated them n they were great
they hated me I had a couple of nuns
that man oh we did yeah I mean I went to
public school they were like downright
abusive
one really had it in for me they're
known for that yeah I used to [__] with
her bed though mhm hate at my guts I
remember squeez in the uh you know the
little thing on the water fountain the
little knob sure I broke it off and I
had it in my hand she she she it was
like the rock she put her hand around me
and squeezed it in my
hand old
[__] it's like man hands like that
wasn't a Twist
Off yeah I didn't like the I didn't like
the younger people when I was younger
when I was developing as a writer and as
an artist in my high school years you
what I had a couple of really good
English te when I started reading like
uh The Catcher in the Rye and and uh uh
when you started getting deep really
started finding yourself yeah you're
talking about this guy like it's Robin
Williams in the Dead Poet Society
meanwhile he's driving a 1986 Volvo sees
the day boys he's got a roommate and
[__] he was great getting a ride home
with you and your
mom can we drop off Mr
beakman yeah man that happened at the
theater one time you really do have some
rosecolor glasses when you're looking
back at stuff halfway through the
catcher of the rice sticks halfway
halfway through St I disagree with that
halfway through studying at The Nine
Pages he already LED I read the whole
thing okay it's one of the only books I
ever read I've read about five books I
tell people that I read a lot more quip
raged yeah no yeah that's your number I
read that the old man in the sea Atlas
Shrugged um is that just shrug Cherry
what's that what's that cherry cherry
International I was going to say the
Fleshlight
manual Jerry was a nudie mag oh yeah
yeah which you don't remember this that
when I how do you know yeah I do [__]
tell me what I remember when I lived in
New York uh the first time the magazine
stores usually just have porn out sure
it was always like up in the top and it
like I'm tell dude I remember was
hitting a little no when I first got up
here late 90s it was out everywhere all
right yeah they had him in the
cellophane and it would have like a it
would be like a three yeah it was C I
mean wasn't showing you seal something
sure you knew it wasn't a [__] Sports
illustrat I could tell you that uhhuh
that was big for a guy my age at that
swimsuit edition that ends up at your
house your buddy's house you're walking
with a couple of pages that shout out to
Petra mova found her about
El mcferson me they never did it for me
athletic bodies on the beach it's
tasteful too one pieces doing nice one
pie I like a nice one piece and then
they went to paint it on oh yeah
remember that year I got real screwy it
was all downhill from there where do you
go from that can't put those daisy dukes
back on this guy got spray painted boobs
here I remember coming home we had a
long driveway over a creek and my
brother and the what hold
on
hold that that says nothing about how I
pictured the home you grew up in a long
driveway over you were one of those
families long you had water on the
property long driveway Circle Drive whip
your back around I thought you lived in
a condo yeah that was later on this was
this was when this was at the height
when I was really young okay could you
like play in the creek feed the feed the
fish and stuff it wasn't that deep
talking about an ankle deep creep it
sounds like a puddle more of a cck if
you will shout out to a corre would it
swell up when it storms I don't remember
a swell I I do remember coming home and
seeing my brother in the neighbor kid
having trying to reassemble a Playboy
they had hidden and then it had gotten
wet and they were like they were trying
to reassemble it like the FBI outside of
Enron to put shredded documents back
together doing that's one thing but
doing that rock hard is man you might as
well have a gun to the back of your head
oh man those hormones were pumping we
were from the age of where where uh we
would print them out on paper like CU
somebody cuz you couldn't get your hands
on a I mean if you were 13 at that when
I was
13 oh man Kevin what are you doing that
oh well you had you had to map it out
and sometimes you hear the garage door
open this guy's down there like
Gutenberg aort
aort I'll never forget my [__] th
page book working the Britain press he's
got ink all over his face and his
hands de you little bird well that's how
you had to do it hey Ben Franklin Take
It Easy will well what the [__] else I
didn't have a car Book of Eli over here
I that's all in Braille I didn't have
a I didn't have a I didn't have a call I
couldn't get your hands on have a fake
ID and streaming not whatever you want
to call it you couldn't watch videos
like that at the time on dialogue so it
was mostly just getting your hands on
pictures
and at that time they were still all
spread out and then free ones was the
first real site you would go to and you
could look and you would print them out
for from there oo Chloe Jones you're
pushing for a color printer that
Christmas huh oh yeah I remember I
thought you wanted a Nintendo no no no I
I want the Epson state-ofthe-art
three in one I'm making
copies I got a book report leave me
alone why is the printer in the
bathroom no a lot of people did that for
sure I mean we would do it we'd go over
my buddy's house and he had uh we would
print it out there he had all the
accessories so we everybody print out
their own thing and then head Head On
Wayward all right let's come pick me up
let's spitball on this on Monday boys
Circle back I think we got enough done
for the
day I'll see you guys when school's done
you're all wearing short sleeve button
Downs
d
one sleeve rolled
up that was the age cuz magazines were
phased out and or you couldn't get your
hands on them and video was VHS and [__]
but you were a you had maximum you had
all that stuff maximum Maxum yeah but
that yeah you could get your hands on
Maxum but then there's real naked they
were they were just there was real naked
women on the internet you could look at
but you couldn't always get your you
know you couldn't always sometimes the
computer was in the family room like
somebody's dad with a popup ad it's real
naked women online waiting to meet
me real naked women that makes you sound
like you never saw one before at that
time I hadn't what are you talking about
wasn't until early in my 30s okay let's
talk about DraftKings baby shout out to
the Kings DraftKings Sports books an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL playoffs and playoff season baby
let's go is here to spice things up for
the playoffs new customers can bet five
bucks on any game and get 2 instantly in
bonus bets giving away bonus bets over
there free coin baby wo put it all on
them baby let's go whether you got a
little skin in the game when you have a
little when you have a little skin in
the game everything is more exciting you
ain't got to tell me that I chase the
dragon download draft almost ruined
Christmas Day download the draftking
Sportsbook app now and use code ay new
customers as the big man said uh can bet
just five bucks and get $200 instantly
and bonus bets only on draftking sports
book with code a y the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit www. 800 gambler. net have that
saved in my phone in New York call
8778 hope Andy or text hope Andy 467 369
Haim Machi if you're in Connecticut help
is available for Pro for problem
gambling call 8887 89
7777 talk about the Lucky Sevens or
visit pcg.org please play responsibly on
Beal on behalf of Boot Hill Casino and
Resort in Kansas 21 plus age ver varies
by jurisdiction void in Ontario they can
kick rocks yeah bonus bets expire 168
hours after ISU so get them in gang cdk
ng.com football for eligibility and
deposit restrictions terms and
responsible game resources do it apply
Kip butcher box shout out to the Box
just a favorite of ours here at Ru
garbage for years Toon's got her freezer
stocked with meat talking free range
we're talking grass-fed grass Fage while
caught better better than a roadkill
you're used to eat man whatever you get
at the supermarket yeah they can kick
rocks gang get butcher box we know
you've been sucking down Christmas and
New Year's Eve cookies for the last
couple of weeks weeks clean it out with
a little protein you know what I'm
saying let them pick your package they
send it over whatever they give you it's
top shelf stuff get some nice pork get
some nice chicken get some ribs get some
hamburger meat it's fantastic yeah uh
they have exclusive member deals recipes
you can try they have curated custom box
plans or you can do your own they give
you Theirs Whatever you want I lean to
them cuz they know what they're doing
they do you're not going to get better
meat mhm and the shipping is always free
they got an awesome bargain for ay
listeners cuz they love us and we love
them here
new members get 2 lb of ground beef 3 lb
of chicken breast or 2 lb of salmon for
free in every order for whole year God
dang it plus they get $20 off your first
order sign up you're going to have
ground beef coming out the Wazoo sign up
today and put your boox use the code ay
to choose your free offer and get $20
off that's free protein for a whole year
at butcherbox.com use the code ay do it
do it I hi on this might be a little
risque a well we started off with you
know that might get
cut did you ever uh accidentally see
something when you were young that you
didn't want to see I think I know where
this is
going fatherhood tools office Patty how
you doing no oh
god mother what the f I don't want to
look at her I didn't mean like that
that's a weird way to put
it okay uh no like someone naked yeah
caught a distant relative coming out of
the shower she's about 85 at the time
yeah no I don't think I ever I don't
think I ever caught any of that no
slipping out of the shower like a bad
avocado what about you [__] Creek you
ever seen anybody washing up down at the
[Laughter]
Quarry guy sifting for gold in that
thing
no everyone Southern upbringing everyone
kept it real tight I think everyone put
a towel on before they open the curtain
you know what I mean sure I think I was
uh I think probably my dad in like a
locker room or changing somewhere like a
water park but that's like he wasn't
nobody was water park completely naked
the 9s shout out to Raging Waters yeah
it
was uh I don't know I'm pulling water
park in my head but I don't think it was
that maybe that gym I was talking about
uh a couple episodes ago um yeah but
that simple like not hiding it like just
uh you know sure changing and a I I mean
this was a shocking moment I remember
the first time I saw gray
pubes yeah at the at the new town
Athletic Club was in the parking
lot hey Mr Robertson how you doing how
you doing Mrs oal uh yeah I didn't know
they I didn't know they turned colors
too White House Tour got a PE at Laura
Bush I didn't know what to
expect you ever tour the White House
what what I feel like we I've been in
there no as a kid they don't do it I
think they do tours there I think you
would know if you've been in the white
house if you had been in the white house
you would was the only thing you would
ever talk about no I thought it was kind
of also true we I thought we did
something don't they have a little part
where you can walk in and yeah they they
have it we were supposed to go
like I'm pretty sure supposed to go like
September 18th or something called it
off they put that on lockdown it was at
seventh
grade instead instead we spent the
weekend at a CIA black site getting
worked over dude in the first like two
months of school we were supposed to go
to Washington DC tour everything and New
York City clamped it down
man I know talk about a bad year tore
the American Airlines plant
put the Kush on all that yikes yeah yeah
I'm pretty sure we did that you went to
City Hall in Bluebell and they lied to
your fat ass yeah you dude if I mean
you're such a if you were in the White
House first of all you'd be throwing
that in everyone's face I think we were
be sitting here with a [__] red tie
and suit we I didn't go for some reason
Senator Congressman how are you little
American flag pin I know we were
supposed to go to the Easter egg hunt on
the lawn what lawn on the Great Lawn
whatever it's called the South 40
whatever they got down there didn't pass
a security check I don't know what it is
um what's it called the southern law no
no no they told him that he wasn't
camera ready where the H Hey listen you
got to lose 15
kid get the news is here come on
chocolate on your face already they did
that to me on double dare I know that's
why they didn't cast me on double the
tube got stuck in the mouth who is the
most famous person you met up
until
18 um up until 18 uh where like if
somebody like gun to your head who's the
most famous person I saw Michael Spinx
at a at the Philadelphia Airport we were
picking somebody up you met you had some
sort of interaction we said what's up my
mom let us go over and say what's up to
him okay he was a big fighter Big boxer
sure um when I was probably 13 or 14 I
think I've told you guys this I caded at
filmont Country Club in Philly for their
Celebrity Golf Tournament uhhuh um Chris
Carter was in in our group but I didn't
we didn't carry his bag me and my cousin
got into the fight in front of him and
he had to break it up um but I met
Charles Barkley okay Keith buers was
there uh who was who is the person
you've spent you were in their company
not just like hey what's up like that
dinner with Jack
Nicholson who are you hanging out with
that's what no nobody I'm asking what is
your printed
porn what's the highest hey Jackie boy
check this out
I'm not I don't think they're that ain't
Angelica Houston H nothing on that
obviously I don't think they're famous
but somebody who in they probably owned
like a used car lot or something he slap
box Billy Bob
thoron do you see what I'm saying like
who is like holy [__] so and so's going
to be there well I've told you this uh
I've told you this recently my dad's uh
where my dad was stationed in w B in
aoka was right next to W was right next
to the ABC affiliate I okay Channel
negative3 it was only 36 and 10 back
then these guys were like movie stars
yeah 3 six and 10 was big in our area
and they had they had this big kid show
that was on there in the morning called
uh Miss Judy or no Hatchy matachi was
the name of it uh yeah I think you
mentioned yeah yeah yeah and I loved it
I thought she was awesome right you
thought she was hot and then we looked
her up she she was about 80 years old um
I hung out with her a pretty good amount
that day dated off
and hung out with her you're front of
the trailer catching heater my dad was I
was working as a keygrip uh she was nice
she looked me in the eye asked me how my
day
was no we were hanging out there cuz my
dad was working the ton or something
like that yeah there like a booth or
something sure tons used to be huge
uhhuh and when was the first time you
were on television the first time I was
on
TV
the first time was the Jim Gaffigan show
first time having not even the new
nothing the news I don't know what am I
wanted man I was on the news as a kid
yeah that big hog of yours in the
newspaper in every county in North
Carolina freak Show spotted in in the
hills of North Carolina the reason they
call it North
kakalaka yeah we going have to change a
name from Bigfoot to I don't know what
good
Lord yeah I was I was part of an allal
baby power PL boy
over did your mom eat a lot of paint
chips when she was having you hey power
lines get over
here oh God I was for what I was part of
an all boys dance troop what who are you
boys to
[Laughter]
boys yeah an all boys dance troop it was
like a ballet class uh a little modern
thrown in uh did you have those things
what the ribbon yeah the sticks I didn't
have the wrist exity for that man
imagine that little F imagine that hog
and those little [__] spandex pants
on YouTube dancing around to put it on
Cinemax it's
pg-15 Yonder bags
[Laughter]
people folks no cell phones don't you're
going to want to take a picture of this
when you see
it they said he's eight but I haven't
seen his birth certific but we're going
to take his word for
it a weener is at least
18 I'm sorry tby please continue that's
all I got what kind of what age was this
oh maybe nine maybe 10 ballet you were
doing ballet could you get up on your
feet on your toes not with those things
oh no no no no no well it's like what
what was the song you were dancing to I
I you know I honestly couldn't tell you
I can remember some of the moves though
there was a lot of box step and uh the
crisscross like your wide receiver doing
that drill where you run sideways [__]
what's that called God damn it just
switch them up as You Go Karaoke doing
karaoke yeah oh sure I can't remember
name dopy D um okay wow I never I never
fell in any of those classes like that I
took a lot of them very embarrassing
none of like we never did wait this is
before uh Sleepaway school oh yeah yeah
this is before Middle School you've
lived a Million Lives you were doing
electives in elementary school no it was
like after it was like outside of school
it was a club yeah yeah it was like it
was like once a week on like Friday
nights or something horrible yeah like a
strip hall or something man it's like
how girls do gymnastics Je Jesus yeah
and we had to commute like 45 minutes or
an hour Man 10 Ines in tiar is over
[Laughter]
here that sucks dude anything on a
Friday night get better be basketball
practice get the [__] out of here oh it
was brutal dude we had CCD on Tuesdays
and that sucked nothing worse than that
nothing worse than that you get out of
school and you got to go to [__]
religious SCH like five oh you got a wo
down dinner you're missing your shows
make programs everyone's [__] picked
up it's already dark out suck same book
every time worst book club
ever and my teachers were the worst oh
man I remember this guy this guy had a
this guy had a package on them too
though this thing was flopping around he
always wore corduro and they were a
little too big so he had like a big you
know he had like a big pouch on them
things man like a kangaroo father son
the Holy Spirit y i remember being like
this guy can't be happy I just remember
looking at him his wife would [__]
talk [__] to his face in class in front
of a bunch of [__] 10-year-olds and
we were all like dude have a backbone
will you go out and get some other [__]
Ernie you going to take that [__] what
are you doing she ain't even that hot
[__] breaking your balls in a in a
bunch of in front of a bunch of kids
when you were a little kid you realized
[__] like that man it was I remember
like [__] stand up for yourself Eddie
what are you doing that was the saddest
part about about it like then Jesus died
on the cross I'm like you're dying in
front of me pal this sucks you're
killing me man what the hell at least
you got away from that bll breaker for a
couple of
days yeah that was that was that was odd
and then she got pregnant when she was
our teacher and then wait I don't
understand you had two people teaching
your it was the first and only time that
ever happened Church H yeah to school
yeah at the you know at St
beads
um St beads St bead's the venerable um
that was the that was the parish St
Fanatics
Philly uh and then I dude yeah just like
they started had they they were having a
she got pregnant in the middle of the
Season or whatever they're called and
he's explaining that to us and the
Miracle of Life and I was like dude you
stin yeah it won too many Schlitz what
are we talking about Buddy it ain't
yours I hate to break it to you yours
was a rerun quit lying all right let's
quit screwing
around let me do it I don't know why you
do
this
guys but that's neither here nor there
we got a gosh darn Family episode on our
hands when you know uh you know with the
Segways lately jeez man the big man's
all thumbs today when you sign up for to
patreon we'll we'll ask you get your
chance to you get your stink rubbing off
on me you'll get
uh your question read on the air that's
just how to do it patreon gets the first
crack at it cuz they're they're homies
uh this one's from Sky Luke $10 Homie
first time long time one of the first
1,000 patrons there you go thank you bu
shout out to you big dog are you garbage
if your dog bit a door to door vacuum
salesman PS my mom felt so bad she
bought 3,000 $3,000 vacuum off them
Jesus yeah I don't uh those guys had it
coming I didn't like that at all every
once in a while while I might have
mentioned there would just be some Bozo
at the house with an Electrolux yeah we
never had that I didn't like it throwing
brick dust on your carpet yeah don't you
got a shop what are you doing here buddy
it's called America Online she always
got them that way too she never bought a
vacuum cleaner at the I mean that's the
stereotypical one is the door Todo
vacuum cleaner sale that's like out of
movies I don't think I first of all my
mom's probably had four vacuum cleaners
my whole life mhm literally four I got a
question for you did you ever have the
one that was like oh yeah like the tube
to the to the to the the skateboard like
the package oh yeah man I remember the
first time we got those we got it
secondhand I think it was like my Ants
or something and I you mean it look like
it looks like a little dog like a little
car it's like a little B it's look like
a piece of luggage yeah but it's long
it's like rectangle has four wheels on
it mine was square square yeah it looked
like a overhead luggage package with
like wheels on it and a to ran from that
to the handle I'm saying it wasn't
self-contained in the one no we never
had that that was you never had the
self-contained n that was big money I
thought oh I don't think or maybe the
other way we had the one that had the
the thing it had a hose and then it was
like a long like a looks like a hot dog
well it looked like the paty would just
stick the tube in Foley's
mouth um like Kirby yeah had four wheels
on it I guess ours was a newer version
of that and it blew out the back and I
would follow her around from vacuum
smells all right i' follow her around
yeah I'd put my head right behind it and
take a little nap while she was doing
the floor and then wake up and then
follow her and I just felt that warm air
blowing on me it's probably horrible for
you you think 1970s vacuum cleaner D
just crushing me in the face was a birth
birth sight of meso
mesothelioma um when I was a dog walker
at a dog bite a guy I've never we none
of our dogs ever actually bit anybody
oh it was so bad I needed the money so
bad I couldn't afford to lose the client
and I the guy was like what are you
doing the dog got a hold of his thigh
dude what kind of dog uh little wiener
dog named Maddox real bastard a little
Doxon yeah they can be a little high any
little dog don't play around cute as a
button I love a little little tiny docks
and little oh not this guy let me tell
you his walks got short and I started
stealing his owner's
liquor I had it coming this guy's here
biting people I got to do something to
pass the time something to pour on the
wounds really did you did the guy have
to did you have to do a like a police
report or whatever I ran away pretty
quickly you ran away that's when you
scoop that dog with the little legs cuz
he can't keep up oh dude I was yanking
just going hey stop my dog man I'm so
sorry this guy's going what the hell he
was freaking out rightly S I would have
[__] beat your ass yeah it was bad
news damn yeah I don't I we've never I
never had anything how far away you were
I was pretty quick yeah I would all
right better hope I don't find you put
some peroxide on that
um yeah that's
uh I feeling bad though I don't know I
me guys come banging on the door if
someone came in and I let them give the
pitch and then my dog bit them I oh he
also says I had to drive four hours the
next day to return it I do have to say
that the the dog no the vacuum so I
guess you just bought it off the guy in
the moment the mom just said okay and
then like next day you're the dad got
home was like what are you out of your
mind probably just felt bad in the
moment you just [__] the guy uh yeah we
never had any door to door salesman
indoor dog never been anybody
which was good I think had the dog get
into a tussle before with another dog my
old dog Mike the German Shepherd M this
when he was he was he was an outdoor
indoor dog this was the early 80s it was
a rough he was in a dogghouse on a huge
chain and he would bark every night
anything that would come anywhere near
the place and SM you know in the winter
he would sleep inside and all that stuff
but he got into it with the Husky next
door man sounds like a nice neighborhood
it was like Rocky 3 these two were going
at
it they're under the L nuts a husky and
a German Shepherd wo they
were swinging we were freaking out wait
the dogs were boxing I want a good clean
fight
[Laughter]
garate ear of the Dragon had just come
out all the craze n they were going at
it man everybody freaking out also as a
note from the we talked about in the
Chay episode that guy the big guy who
fights the two yeah I saw that message
he runs the he runs the like it's called
like fight circus or something he's like
the head of the promotion which is
pretty badass he's putting himself in
the [__] head car just wailing on
guys yeah it's all right shout out to it
Baby K let's talk about Helix hey Helix
you guys sick of tossing and turning at
night cuz you're sleeping on some crappy
mattress from crappy mattress store go
over to Helix take the quids they'll
find out exactly how you like to sleep
and they'll give you a mattress that
complies to all those specifications
whether you sleep hot you sleep cold
whether you sleep fat whether you sleep
light whatever it is they got you
covered it's the best mattress in the
world baby we both got one mhm just take
the quick quiz on the website to get
match with the perfect mattress I'm a
Twilight man myself yeah you are you
even got 100 nights free trial to try it
out if you don't love it just send it
back and get a refund no questions asked
nothing to lose that's good the people
people Helix are good people uh they got
a mattress for Big and Tall sleepers
like the big men mattress for kids
options for stomach sleepers side
sleepers back sleepers no matter how you
like to catch those Z's Helix has you
cover oh that's a nice copy that's
pretty good Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for garbage listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage and use the code
Helix partner2 that's helixsleep.com
garbage code helix partner2 this is
their best offer yet and it won't last
long with Helix better sleep starts now
so do it yeah baby good queue good queue
my I I don't know if I mentioned this to
you before but my dad we were at some
type of uh State Fair and they were
doing um like a demonstration for like
Hood cleaner whatever it's called like
some type of waxing thing and my dad
under his breath was like oh this [__]
doesn't work oh and the guy heard him
you told me like what was that Baldi
yeah he bought like [__] four boxes
of it mhm sat in my garage for like 25
years yeah that was the thing when I
worked the I used to work those home
show and trade shows selling Home
Improvements and man but like the guys
with the nonstick pans and the they
would come and they are like they are
salesmen dude they're showmen they get
they draw a crowd they get you going
they get the employees from the other
booth walk I'm sitting there looking be
like maybe I do need a nonstick band
that's how those guys make it up to
Billy May St of course yeah yeah yeah
they're like Road Comics they're like
yeah really hone your skills uhhuh I
remember I saw one guy there was this
guy was a comic I was at the we were at
the Atlantic City boat show I was
selling Home Improvements it was a
blizzard no one like 10 people showed up
we ended up getting a refund uh nobody
showed up but the water skiing squirrel
was there which blew my mind apparently
there's more than one so I that's your
celebrity I didn't well I didn't get to
spend time with him but I did see him
from afar called you backstage but this
comic I had just started comedy and the
guy across from me was just selling a
bunch of stuff so we just started there
was no like
hey I'm like we were selling Home
Improvements other guys were selling
cleaning products this that that this
guy just had like a couple of books a
little bit of this a little bit of that
and we started talking here he was a
comic I guess like left over from the
80s or you know early 90s or whatever
and that's what he would do he was just
selling random stuff yeah at a boat show
how do you get a booth doesn't it have
to be connected to a boat no you could
just sell anything they just any vendor
can come essentially yeah so you could
go to a the the car show and and and a
car Show's a little different cuz that's
not vendors there a car show is just
displaying cars okay I'm just imagining
the water skiing squirrel at some Hotel
bar drink it alone chat some what's up
ladies you know I'm the main one they're
all based off me it's my third one this
week Indianapolis last week I me
Columbus
tomorrow you ladies ever been to
Columbus top it all off my dog been a
vacuum salesman yesterday got the
wife like breaking my little
Stones
um but he was like I'm a comedian I had
just started comedy and I was like man
if I ever end up selling [__] at a Bo
did you tell me you were a comedian too
I did I had to I was
networking I was trying to get the name
of the guy he got the booth off of I did
I just started doing open mics I'm like
yeah I started doing open mics in
Phillies I don't know how long I waited
till I said that I'm a comedian you
probably said it before you did it
you're probably [__] you probably
said it in the 70s no with that I was I
was always real uh the the other way I
always thought we all were I would say I
do comedy I said I do yeah it was always
I do comedy yeah I would never say I'm a
comedian mhm I still don't I'll get the
check you guys that is that all one
check ah
sucks uh yeah I think I did do comedy's
good I think I did early cuz I didn't
know and I was like yeah I'm a comedian
after I did it like twice
and then it caught up to I'm like oh I'm
not no like once I saw people do it like
actually comedian or like you know
working to be comedians not even
comedians just working to be a comedian
I was like I'm not that guy you're not
that
guy oh man I didn't know you could do
that you could just show up to a trade
show and just sell it's like a yard sale
it's not a yard sale he had products
what products you said he had books and
stuff yeah he had his joke books but I
think I bought or he G I think he gave
me one sign joke books he had like a
self-published book of jokes with some
of the stuff he was sell he probably had
like some cleaners and you have to I'm
assuming I don't know but I'm assuming
you have to do something you're like
adding value to the [__] to the boat
to the show you're not just like selling
your used roller blades or whatever
you're actually [__] you're like hey
I I sell a bunch of cleaning products
trouble getting around the yacht here
you
go
oh man that was the worst [__] I had a
share got toilet brushes and tupperware
Lids that's kind of what he
had it's Rocky on a boat velcro couple
records I had to share room with a kid
we for like five days we got snowed in
Atlantic City had to share a room with
him and man I would just we would sit
there and I he would film me or record
me snoring because I was snoring so loud
dude and I remember being like dude I'm
sorry and he was sober and I would just
sit there and get blind drunk by myself
cuz they canceled it but we couldn't
leave cuz the snow was so bad were you
in a casino yeah why don't you go play
the tables I didn't have any money what
are you I was what dude I was selling
home improvements in a boat show I
didn't have any [__] cash what are
you talking about I got a free book from
so Home Improvement in
a yeah I was jammed up in a ski
lodge J up that's like an old that's
like an old Street
joke selling I was selling roofs at a
boat show that's what I was doing I was
selling $80,000 metal roofs at a boat
you were just in a hotel room at one you
remember what casino it was I don't
think it's open it might have been like
Bailey's or Caesars or something I don't
think it's open anymore and I would go
down every like hour and we were just
sit in bed cuz there's like couches so
you were just like each sitting in our
bed you can't go outside cuz the weather
was so bad so I would just go down like
every hour on the hour and crank like
two heaters sitting at a [__] slot
machine and I remember the one time I
got yelled at for not playing this they
were like you got to play if you're
sitting here like I just need a heater
sitting in sweatpants and a [__] in a
dirty t-shirt catching heaters selling
txl or whatever that stuff was it's
brutal what was that stuff called
Limestone txl or t CL CLR CLR chlorine
or calcium lime and rust has to be the r
get you right off that lime stuff will
get you in the trouble the stuff that
cleans the
lime off of stuff you know what I'm
talking about no what do you think I'm
cleaning lime off of uh it's a kitchen
it's like a different kitchen spray they
use it to like clean like the grills or
something I don't know but I sprayed it
one time thinking it was something else
and I almost killed like 40 people in
the kitchen yeah cuz it was right in
front of the fan and like all of a
sudden prep cooks are falling out you're
making muster gas in the yeah what the
you doing my cousin Sean who's a a
listener shout out to you he had uh he
was working a summer job in down the
shore in the kitchen and he was like
they told him like clean up and he did
ammonia and bleach in the in the like in
the small back kitchen man they had to
clear out the whole restaurant everybody
had to fall out talked about jammed up I
don't think he I don't think he was
asked back the next
summer uh all right let's see here this
one's from Calvin $10 Homie first time
long time is it garbage if your dad
pulls a knife on your brother during a
PO a free pool night at the bowling
alley ouch there was nothing classy
about that statement no dad pulls a
knife on your brother free pool at a
bowling
alley yikes dude that ain't good bad
news I wonder what he he's like I wonder
if he's sitting at home waiting on an
answer maybe I want let's let's send
this to the pros and see what they
really say about
it uh yeah that's [__] I mean also
playing that much pool with your parents
that's like a buddy's thing yeah you
shouldn't be shooting pool with your
parents where it ends in a [__] fist
fight the only thing I ever played with
my dad was
catch uh a board game or basketball or
football something like that pool I
never shot pool at my dad yeah that's
nuts that's like [__] that's like
Hustler [__] shooting
stick yeah that's what I'm saying I mean
we did a lot of knee football as kids
sure yeah loveing and there was always a
thing where we football in a fresh
carpet woo they just put down Turf dudee
it was like this we every house my dad
my dad was big on running houses once he
started making some money they were
divorc he didn't buy so he'd rent a
house and obviously not have he would
furnish the living room like the family
room but then the dining room or so
there was just like always a wide open
living room and a wide open dining room
that's nice man that was like the
goddamn super bow yeah that's all right
and you you would hit him with something
you you know you'd hurt him a little bit
next play he was [__] out for a blood
elbow [__] hang [__] hang you out
the dry across the middle W the refs are
really letting them go this game letting
them play the middle-aged man seems
angry
H all right let's see this one's from
I'm tap stats or something I don't know
I can't pronounce it uh $10 doofus never
had one R are you garbage if you've ever
played the slot machines at a gas
station these are popping up more and
more specifically in Pennsylvania too I
don't know if like proper slots proper
slots are like now in 7-Eleven and stuff
that is so gas station 7-Eleven are you
thinking how do you do you think that's
going to bring in good clientele well
here hear me out right cuz we were I was
and if I was the guy hold on if I was
the guy working behind the counter I
don't want that what I'm a bartender now
I got to entertain I got to deal with I
I got to deal with these guys B yeah
yeah listen I yes as the employee that
probably sucks as the end user cuz I was
down there and I was talking to my buddy
Pat we were talking about going to the
casino Parks Casino maybe look for a
little action no no no no the
Sito and he goes you know what would be
a good
time the 7eleven off Route One has slot
machines and if you think about it you
got everything you need there sure you
can get beers snacks snacks heaters you
can pop outside smoke heater you don't
have to wait for the waitress to come
around with a drink is she coming back
is she not coming back those rollers are
hot chili dogs day long as the day is
long that's in a dirt bag mentality
that's got everything you need how many
how many slots are we talking I I don't
know for the boys I don't want to be
taking turns yeah the one I I the only
one I've seen there was two are they
paying out there yeah cuz the I went to
a bar and [__] when I was home for so
doesn't that mean that they have to have
a minimum of cash on hand yeah they went
up my buddy Vinnie with the skinny hit
for like 8 on one of those machines and
they paid them out right there cash see
that's giving away how much money is at
the place too I mean it's a bar Bar's
got 800 bucks on them no I thought even
7-Eleven no well 7-Eleven got cash
7-11's got more than $800 cash on them
it's in a safe I'm saying if you say if
if if you start advertising that they
got slot machines and one of the Slots
machines like a million dollar thing
that means they got a million you got to
go to the the 7-Eleven clerk isn't
paying you out a million dollars dude
you got to go to the state office go
back into the office you want that in
small bills or taquitos he op up some
champagne he's got a big check yeah no
that's like I think it's like Petty
payouts they would give you like if you
hit the scratchers or whatever sure yeah
they got a couple of G's in there I
think everybody knows yeah you know what
I never understood even to this day
sometimes you go to like a smaller place
or whatever and you ask for like uh you
ask for you give them like a 20 and all
they don't it's like not in a casual
it's just like a box or something and
like a
non-locked did you ever see that say it
again it's in like a cigar box or a shoe
box is where they keep the cash where
and like a mom and pop shop of some sort
and I'm like what do you you're at least
get a cash register for that that's like
bodegas do that [__] all the time just
like you don't know what's under there
right bodegas are like here's a Sig
here's a gun here's 10 grand cat yeah
that that's they got nickel under there
though yeah you would assume right come
on are you crazy or one of them little
bats whack yeah I don't think they got
the nickel I think a lot of them do I I
think there'd be more shootings you
think there's a good amount not of
Bodega owners on the clients lately they
have been popping off shit's [__]
whacking going ham yeah you can always
get the temperature of of uh you know
politics by talking to a a bodega owner
too they give you the real feel in the
neighborhood you know you mention things
that you don't understand we can we can
cut this if you want but I had a couple
of terms that I don't know what they are
I wanted to see if you guys knew what
they were okay things you don't
understand it just made me think that I
had a couple of things I'm I'm I'm
interested things I don't know all right
Zero Sum game what does that
mean what does it mean or where what
where does the saying come from what
does it mean you know both no well Zero
Sum game means no one win it's h if I
lose 10 and I'm using money if I lose 10
bucks there's no winner or loser the
outcome is the same everybody stays the
same it's a zero some game
Toby that right zero some game is a
mathematical representation in Game
Theory and economic theory of a
situation that involves two sides where
the result is an advantage for one side
and an equivalent loss for the other
that doesn't make any sense sure don't
Zero Sum game yeah so if you lose $10
and I win $10 from you that's a zero sum
game because the total number of that
doesn't that's not how I use you still
win 10 bucks so you're using Z 10us 10
zero some game is is a mathematical
representation if the total gains of
participants are added up and the total
losses are subtracted they will sum to
zero yeah so if you win 10 and I lose 10
that's a zero sum game plus 10 but you
won 10 how is it a zero some game cuz
you're you're talking about me this is
talking about the whole game oh the
whole game is minus 10 and plus 10 is
zero oh okay zero change the game
doesn't win anything what no House
Always Wins baby what about quid pro quo
yeah that's Latin right I pro quo is
uh that's quid pro like standard
operating Norms in my head
Toby quidd pro quo a favor or Advantage
granted or accepted in return for
something oh that's right that's what
they were trying to that's what they get
politicians on was it quid proquo did
you give them the contract and hopes for
the kickback scratch my back I'll
scratch yours yeah man that's a good one
everybody knows that that's a zero
Something game right there and the last
one was the gold man I'm dumber than I
thought last one was the Golden Rule
what is the Golden Rule do onto others
as they do to you that's biblical be
nice that's really it yeah don't be a
[__] I don't know we use gole it
something you know what I didn't know I
didn't know about that I feel it's all
over the Golden hour is like the sunset
golden shower the golden hour yeah I
think that's when you have dementia
no that's the Sundown brutal you lying
uh golden hour yeah that's the you see
it uh happy
hour it's 5 o' somewhere uh golden hour
is right before the sunsets yeah you
it's when you get the best light it's
like the glow the golden hour there's
that I had no idea it's right and I feel
like everybody's been saying it it's
right as the sun goes below the Horizon
you get the cleanest light possible it's
when you they do a lot of filming during
that time wait really oh yeah I thought
it was you'd want the son pointing down
at you well you know huh Hollywood types
yeah who's the most famous person you
ever met uh been in the company of yeah
there was a couple who uh it was because
my aunt but uh he was the mayor at the
time of Philadelphia Ed Randell sure I
waited on him went sleding at his house
really MH that would mean hill with a
kicker at the bottom I waited on him
about 15 years ago yeah nice guy yeah
okay all right uh nice guy was agree
with yeah he would come he was like a
big like if he was around temper I'll
tell you that my my aunt worked very
closely with him and if he was he would
come to like big events for the family
for like my grand like he came to like
my grandparents like 50th Anniversary
nice and stuff like that pulled some
strings to get him at the Cathedral in
uh to have this have the mass there he
had a stady with him was pretty cool
yeah I would always love talking to that
guy that guy would come in and I'd be
like what kind of peie you work love
talking to the muscle the best that was
cool the driver I mean I only met on my
hand maybe those guys can wear a sport
coat oh yeah they F that thing out
retired State Troopers that work in
Security man I think they're act no
those are actual active state troopers
oh yeah that's right oh no you get that
for Life govern because I knew him I not
knew him I he this was after he was the
governor and he had a dude with him oh
yeah that's you might get that for life
that's State yeah yeah that's that's a
trooper is on that detail sweet dude
goons for Life come on goons for life is
awesome that's that doesn't get any
better than that uhuh an ex-president
you just got the Secret Service with you
rolling around that's got to be a bum
detail though sometimes you got to
really like the dude I guess unless
you're with George W then you're just
[__] slugging whiskey smoking cigars
hanging yeah yeah [__] get Jimmy
Carter or something
[__] I got Ross perau [__] dude George W
you're watching college football all day
he's painting having a good time that's
a good time shooting the top off beer
cans
yeah yeah that's all right hopping into
that helicopter is pretty sweet what the
you know when you got to give the salute
when you're hopp into the the air the
Marine one oh yeah you think that's cool
yeah of course it is hopping into the
world's coolest helicopter with Marines
you think that's cool do you
sweet
um yeah wait that's your famous guy he's
not in movies he's not an athlete he's a
politician you're Charles Barkley no the
lady you spent time with was an
80-year-old CBS affiliate whatever she
was she was a local celebrity she was
the mayor of uh of
Philadelphia and world not world famous
locally famous comedian still good
family friend Joe Conlin man of 10,000
voices there you go he would show up and
we' make him do the we'd make him do the
characters and now looking back how much
that had to suck I got a couple of
uncles that you can't mention Jo comedy
I had Joe Conlin down at the the he yeah
Joe Conlin kills it man of 10,000 voices
he was big on uh 610 WIP which was the
The Sports Talk Philly Sports Talk
Angelo cataldi did you know any local
DJs when you were younger uh you ever
meet the gater no my mom they all know
through him through Conlin the G we're
pretty well connected in Philadelphia uh
we we knew the ex mayor if you need a
yxp c
we got you covered more of an MMR man um
never met the Geer I might have met John
de bella never met John debella oh you
did I think so yeah he came to our
school for some reason we know Bob Kelly
I don't want to brag you know Bob Kelly
I think that's his name no I was just
trying to he does like the he broadcasts
an hour every every week down the shore
at uh Cort Pier oh we were there yeah
yeah yeah we know Bobby comes over he
says hi to the table I don't know him
but you know Showbiz to Showbiz we give
each other a it's pretty good yeah my
family knows all of those local Philly
local Philly Gator with the heater
couple of Mummers couple of Mummers
um yeah that kind of that kind of thing
get you concert tickets get you out of
parking tickets we're like we're really
we're really well engaged in that realm
other than that I was on the I was on
the uh I was on TV for the one time I
was in the Thanksgiving Day Parade that
was it and my mom might have been lying
just to make me feel good oh I might
have not made the cut but she said she
saw me no but what I was going to say is
that they when they were picking kids
for double dare season one this was huge
that had the lady walked right by me
looked at me and just kept moving oink
oink what' you say did you find a candy
in your pocket a hey bud thanks for
coming out snacks are in the
bag hi wanted to be on it so bad I
didn't know what it was I just knew it
was a casting call you're on a couch I
you don't all we got to wrap it up gang
we love you to death and we'll see you
next week peace peace